hey I'm Vince I'm Johnny we're the
co-founders of social talent here in
Dublin we actually met in the Cayman
Islands in an Irish bar as one does and
Johnny made a proposition that I would
make millions from the from setting up a
recruitment agency within six months
we've burned all our money with young
kids and we kind of said you know what
maybe there's a business and kind of
teaching people a new way of recruiting
everything that we did was quite
different each user on a platform get to
they've got access to a gamified
learning platform but lots of content
and best practice of short Michael
learning videos tips on how do you
social media tools web tools different
ways to be more productive it's kind of
like Netflix for HR and recruiting
professionals yeah actually can scrap
the rest with dusty and so one day I get
a call from one of our team saying
Johnny what you need is money for like
what do you mean what I hate is money
for so she sends me a copy of an email I
apparently in center saying I needed her
to send me phones then two minutes later
another email from somebody else a
customer saying what's this all about
you know I'm on the CEO of the company
and I my mail is used to go into lots of
people and this was a disaster I got
onto one of my colleagues to say we need
to fix this this is crazy how do i do it
in a few minutes she'd got contact makar
I'm with the Google team and within a
few hours we had a bit of code from the
guys and support and all of a sudden the
whole thing was resolved you know I
didn't expect as a smaller business that
we get that support it was a huge
surprise with huge comfort to me to get
that the reputational damage of that
could have been massive it just takes
one or two customers to believe that was
awesome for Google to come and help us
like that within a few hours that's
prices
I would like to say that I do get emails
from Johnny asking for money and I don't
believe they're spoofs and and try as I
might I don't think Google will be able
to help me